W
HITOP T
TINFNOICONKS BOO ANDHO AUTRS
YEVER WKEEEND B TKOOVITEV LEONSI
R SEOUS S.ADREER
YEMILKOAT RAJKIWSSER HE
TO TTGHOEB CELTE AEB DUT
TILLCOEC E OONFAYSSST THA
HINAMES M OERWNCETIULFADTE
TYENIDTI
A-FOR WLD MOUAMSEL WITH TSEN
ILOF M OONLISFLO FOL
RSWE.
SHE I ASHOOU HSELDAM NE FOR HER
O
SOKND AROLIC BMA IGEUT
REOSSE T LETIN HAV B AGYOD
P HR
ANLEOP WO TEL SORL F
ITINSTMEE UTDILIIONSNA.TY
MY BYOD TKLACES FEAMOV LE
SHIEFRND B AIPNDLRAETYAND AHE T
ICINTREBEAT WF OLIEX SUATYND A
RPOWE FLIEENGLL SMAECNE O SDON
ANFUOW PERLHE TEX NH BTOTN I
AN CT OUOF.TRONOL
INKO RECNGNIH WIT AEL LEV OF
SCCSUESHA TTAS H BROHT HER
BOTH PNAIND A PEASLEURMI ELY
INESIGSTAT HERWN OVO EINLVG
BEHESEF TVE PERYNERS DICAMS O
A
REUL CTUHA TTMO COMFIDIESHE T
BMAFELEY AND DHE TMYHOICTO
EEBETW WNHOHE SD S  IANE'W HOS'S
EIPERCD.VE
ILEMY RWSAJATKO IKISN I
CONVSATION TENS HIEVITGIN WH
HAIN RAOSHE T EALTODIRI
ORREDICTOR AIOUD AT NK YEWOR
MA
WZIGANEREHE THEUTIR FST
HEBLPUISLY EDMI''SS EAYIN BUYG
SEMYLF BAC WHICHAS W T
'ZIGANEM'S D  RSTEAOFECPIE EMA
TH
ARYE.
EVPRUSIOLYAN HAAS W AHO CO-ST
F
'NPR'NVS IIAIBISIL
HEISE  TRUT AHO OFHE TOO BK
E ENDF OEN M A HNDAS AOLS
WR
TEITN FOR THE ATLTIANCHE T
WA
ONINSHGTOS PTND A N THE
EWYO
MOERRK AER ONGTH
R LATEHEIN TAMRO PGRS.
'' LEOVO TYOEA HR UR QSTIO
DAN Y'O' BLLENV IOEDIT T LEINP U
HEAT TTA SMIINNDG OPHOS IN
EILE AERIS
LLFO TINOWGNT EHEVEDIG SNEOO B
S
BWILL FEOR S TE ALINN MHEAI
LO
THANK YOULL AGA A BINHOTE HER
AAND HTEOM FOREINGIT WH US
T,NITOGH P ANDASLEEN JOI MEN I
GING A WARM.EL WMECOO TLY EMI
RAI OWJKSKNND ANHAEN RAHOS
YOEVERNENK THA YOU SOFOUC MH .
RE
REG INHE
DNWEIRFSES OHI TSEN MOM FTORNE O
OCOSENDFNG BEI LEIV ANDAV HGIN
LOPPELEE.IV
.HI
ERYO.
LEPEOP AE  HREERIT ESOXCG.IN
KTHAN YOU C FORTOINOMG
WA.GTINON
THKANOROU Y FAV HGINE. M
ANTHKOU Y FORNG BEI
ER HE.
, YEAH.FEI EL
THIS B SK OOISONPEO RS.AL
ATTH I WASHI TINNKGIK LEF I I
JU
ST DE RHTN I IT' 'LLE B
TO
THEPYRA S.SIESON
SOO SIK L TEHEHE TON CRUSTCT I
MECAP UH WITIKS I L IE''AH OPR
A'OU Y'DERE A.LE
CAN WHADOE  T
ETID D GO TAT WCHT. I
I FLEEDEH BIN BUT' I 'MCK QUI
LER.NE
PEFUY IEAAN C YH,E W CANO D
.IT
YO DJUU STITO  DINOP.
Y OH MD.GO
AHYEE WAN C DO I
WEL''URO D OES BT AT SND A I
SO
OU YAL CHEDLE TOO BK BY MY,OD
WHEE IH F ELIL KES.ODMBIE
ETHHI TNGBO AUTHE TOO BKT' '
SLI
IKEN MYEA HD TIT T ILES
KELIOO LKT AY M
OD BY.
STOPKI LOONGT  AMYOD BYE LIKT I
IKSHA L'OU Y'RET LM AOSKIASNG
PELE TORO STF OE COMNT IO THE
COONSAERTIHT RIG AY.WA
T TISHA IOU YRONENNTTIIK LEOU Y
O
DULAV HT JEUSAL CDLE IT
ENGHI.
Y'I' OLIS FEET SROM
, WELLOEATTH D'S'OUT ' IT'S
LIYRI FDADIRE PJU I ACEND''
GO
ANNE BES HON WH YO
Y,UMH,EA IEA M IN, DELINEFITY
THINTHK RE TATHE AAS WT PARF
HAME T LTEDIKLA P WNGYIHIT THE
IDEA OF PPLEINHI TNKGE LIK
GLLROINHE TIRYE ES ANDNG BEI
,LIKEH ELY RWSAJATKOKIRO W
A BKOO CLEALDY MOD BYIK L RHTIGE
ANDHE TNNG USIHAT
PTONECCEOPNIO HULEFLY TO
U
,KNOW MAY MBEHEEAK TMUY B THE
ROKBO OVE EP, HNEL YOUNO KW,
FRTSO ODEHE T I IASN THEK BOOE B
REMOMP I.TFACUL
SOS,T  IWAOU YNO KAW  NEW IHA WT
WA.OI DNG
INE KWAS W ENGRAMBCIHIOM SET
THATAS WNA GON PALENOTTILY
Y
OPPE.LE
AHYE.
.GOOD
OK
A'M THFOL R .AT
,UM'HE TREA'S SEOLWHE OFIOCTN
THHAOKBO TTAD IHI TNKF OS A
LIHE TUCIS MEDIOATNF O ELYMI
IK LEHE TIG SLSNAAS B
ALY
THATOU YVEEC REI I ADND WTANO T
TABO AUTHA TIK LE ENVE IN
TYOUR LNAEEGEHEEIF T
OPART TFHEOO BKEO T M WAS
LYRMNOALHE WNEOPL AEREOI GNG
TH
PUGROH OERUBTYRTE PRES.EN
'I' LIK THEIG SHALSNA TT CEOM
NSOMFR IEIDHA T C ATRENGFUONSI
TO,OU BUTEE I FIKEN IOU YR
CA BVE ENOREFEEROU Y WE
CO
SCINSOUT.F O I
I'S T ALLHETU SFF TTHAT I WAS
T TKEHEHEUE CST THAAM CEM FROLI
OU TEIDO. YOU
BITIK LE THE FSTIRE TIMOU YIT
IZREALT TEHAE'OTRE N
NEYARSSILHE TIR FSTIM TEHA TT
BYOURASYOD W ANG THIND A T
HE
LEPEOPRT STAEDO T SDENT THA
ALSIGN TO F YOUTSM ROOUE.ID
AHYE.
I MN,EA I TNKHIHA TT I DEDELEVOP
RENG YLYOUND A IAD AOM W'A'
BODYEF BEOR IVE EN UOOERNDST
R
EWKNSEHA WT
WAX S.
SOT  ITPUE M INLL R AEATRY SGEAN
ONSIPOTIFNE O O THE FSTIRAY ESS
I
VE ERLI PUB WEDSHASHIOM SETNG
EDCALLAB BYOMANSEEC BAU IAS W
A ULTRY BUBYBA, SI T WA N IOW
ACOKLO BATK IC PRETUS'ND A I'M
LIKE REAY P TPLEOEUGHOHT IAS W
AN.DU ALT
IKE LOODIK LE AHILD, BUT IID D
LO OERND A IER CINTALY I
STODTE T KDIN O HEAVHI TS
CERIPEEN OF BHOTLI FEE
NGEX
LYREALAWEL SF-EARN IIT P AOSEIV
LSDAN A INEG A NIVATEAY WO, S
NOUYO K AWTID MEDLN IY M M
E
OLSCHOLI FEEHE Y KOUWNO
NTATTENIOT THA I GOT FMRO B
Y
H WHICANSHAT ANMET TTHA T,HE
YOUW KNOAROP PUL GLSIRTE WAN
O
BEEN FRIH WDSITE MND A TGNKHIIN
LI,H, O TT'H' AS GDOO T
N.
BUTHE TNLS AO,NOOU Y KWLI FEE
KE I A HADICE PALNCRIIP
P
RAMY BTR SAPR O I KWNO ISLW AAY
REMBER
HA TT.
YEAH AT TTHA SMA IGE ICKTISNY M
E
AD L OFEHAT.UC SKS
SH WEAS AOM WANESNT IER.NGTILY
I'O' THIPE INK SFYCI TTHA
N
THEK, BOO B YUTOU KW,NOHA W'T'
TH LINPOTHAE,IK W ATREOU Y
SU
TOSPPEDONO D IER MD?IN
WIT IASN MEA T ANDSHIS I R
Y
KI ONDF THATSS EAYN  ILNEGERA
BESO LTYESU , NSYO
OWKN.
I'MNT IDESERTEN IRIXP ELONGHE T
YSWAHA TT WENRY TO T PTEROCT
OT
RHE BOM WEN KDIN OFEA TINCHG
H
EM THED HAR WAYR OINEA TCHG
TH ABO W TUTHELDORND AHE T
Y
THATIR THEUT BEAANDHEIR
ALSEXUNYIT IHE TIRSOD BIE ARE
GGOIN BO TEMEON CSUD AND INK THI
THAT FORMP EXAT TLEHAE VIC
CIPRINORLPA S OTFHTHO TUGHE S
S SINAYG TO MEIK LE YOUUL SHO
UTHTC O SOU YULHODWAE B ARE
F
TH AISNDIK LE IF I D'O'TAT SND
YO BRAAP STRODOM SEBYLS EE
LL KF DIN O
INTHG.
NK TIHI YOU INO KW'ON D'T TNKHI
DAS WTNGOI I NRIESECSA
N
ALA MIOICUSAY W
'ON D'TW  KNOTBU I MNEA IT IN
GE TLRATHAAS W ST OFHE T
PU
BOSRPEINEHD TTHA ESS.AY
IAD H ANBO EX-RIEN WHO MSEOM
SHENL OY HAD A SONND AT A ONE
INPOTE WE WERKI TALNG ABO IUTF
SHAD HAD H AAU D ATEGHR
E
WSAIDLEL I WLDOUE HAVE LIK
YOUVISL MREE ADSUHA TTHE S YB
U
SKNOWYETAD TNHI AND IIK LE
ALT SSTPI UP L MYCHUN BAUSE
ASI WIK LE,T WAILIHA WT
R'U'RT S AMA
AD LY.KEYO
TEA WHIT POO CLSITOLICND A
YO
R'U'NGAL TKI HBO AUTOW Y
WO
DUL SAK MEOUEUR YRTEAU DGHR
STN TSHI TIK LET'H' YSOUOM CE
.ON
USUYO MW KTNOT THA TT'H'E LSIK
REPE FOR AN EINATGIS D
DER
IAND ZEEA RLIT TDHA HN ID MERIN
ITASER H IAST WER HNK THI
GN
THATOU W BLDE PINTEROCT HER
HTDAUGNDER A EGURNSINER H
ERUGDAHT AOO GDUT FEURND AOV LE
E
TUSCAENHEEN WOMRE AED LOV
MOOUUT B Y ORWNAR P
TSEN.
I FLEEIK LERE THE'' A 'REHE'S
MIRWEDESEDIX M IGESASRE TNHE
TH
RE TATHE'' LEIK A THI TNGTHA
ICKSN MY TEA HDTHA YROUAD D
TSAIDO YR MOMHE WNEO P
EPL
LECOMPNTMEED ONER H ON HER
BE.TY
,YEAH HERHE FATR NOT WASER H
THER
.YE
S YNOUAYT  WHAHE WLDOUAY S
?E
S,O ST' THA 'STARF O WHY I
UDINCLEDHA TT INHE.SS EAY
MYTHNDRAFALD WEROU T SAYOY M
MOER, UYO KW,NO YOU S'ULHODN
'T
SAYNK THAOU Y SHE WN
EOOMNE
LICOMPNTSOU ONHE TOUAY W Y
ECOKLO BSEA'OU Y'ONVE DE N
G
DTOERESVE ITND AE HAS W A
LYREALERIO PERNSOND A I
TINTHKTHAE HAD ME HER
EE FL
MEASHA FDORHE TAY W
OOE LDKE ANDOU YW KNO BER HYOD
ULRTPAICNDLYAR AT I WASEOU SRC
SOFMEHAOR F HERND A HERAM FYIL
ICWHHS W IHYHI TNKN I SAYEOM W
ESHK TOOHE TER OTHOU RTE OF LEIK
ATLECEBRER YOUOU YOLNO KW
S
INLOOKATG  YOUTE WHANDRVE AIN K
F
IN SAYGE LIK SHI TSULHOD BE A
O
F CEUR OBUIDPRE  ITN A LOT OF
YS IADT M MEEY  VERARAWEF O
TH W.AY
WAI SERCENDEDIV A YOUNO KW, I
R
BOEIT AUTHI TS T INTHAAY ESS
PLIKE FYIRANGUT BOREA IWHY EN
WAY VER YNGOUIK L SENDIX A AND
WHID DOU YHI TNKT IAS W
AS,KE WT I S ARCOUE OF?OW PER
INEA JTUSEO T B.LE CAR
YE
ITAS WITEF DINYEL AEOU SRC OF
WEPOR.
LIS TKEH'AS WN'UST JNT IY M
FA
LYMI.
ASIT W AOUO,LS YNO K IW,RE GP U
INHE TLY EAR ASRTND A THEGE A OF
KELIHE TT MOSER POWLFU TOM WENO
MEE WER BTNEY SARPES AND POP
ST
D S ARANFUAUBETIN.WOL ME
DAN NT JOTUS MYEN GNATERIOIK LE
MY PARTSED LOV OERLD M
I.
'W'DAT WCH MIK LEILARYNRO MON
EN
E SDOMIKET HOT AND ITAS W
,LIKEKA OY, SE'THO ERSEN M WHO
ENCA BER POW BLFUAUECSEHEY'RE
PR OENIDTSIR TRHE CNSEDOMIA O
H
REIK ROCTA S,RSUT B T ME, IT
TEMSEEDTHA M THETOSFUOW PERL
WMEWONLWEER AHESAY T OSNE WHO
AR
E MTOSEDES DIRY B
EN M.
SO INK THI TTHA AS AYOER VY GUN
IRSPEON OTENSADF FORIKEON M
Y
OR IGEELNTLI OENCR SAFY LEIK
ME SITEE
IDT.
SJUST
KEPO.
AIIT SK TDOOUCO S M THO ME WN
IOO L BDKEK ACON TTHA AND
THBOTGH AE LUTIKT A H
I
NLEARHA TTT THADHO SUL BEHE T
TH
WANT?EDARA PR D YEFODAN
YE.AH
I K I ODINLL RFEA WYTANO TAL TK
THOUABT REBLE URES LDIN PTIORON
OF TK BHEOOAU BEC ISEAV HEOU Y
REHETCDHAT VEOID YOU
ER
HWATC AT IMONYREEDAT WCH IT WHE
I WASRI W TNGTIHEAY ESS
UM, WTAS WOU Y SR
ONECD
TCREWA
NGHI?
I'IO CMUR I IUSF WTASHE T SE.AM
'I' SSO WEIO TNK THI AUTBO
ATHATNDNK THIIK LEHA T'T'HAT
R
DELOPLEOE M TE. FAM
'IT'SUC SH ANDD OEN MOMTCI SPECI
FAARTI OCTFHE TREUL CTU
Y,U
.KNOW
AHYE.
ANI ME, INK THI K YOUWNO WTHA I
EDWANT CO TVEONYN WHE ITE WRO
SSETH E T AAYNDLYRUOW H IEE FL
ABT ITS I I' DON 'TLEEHA TT
TENNCOECD TO I
AS W AOB JHAT IWE SHO UDPO T
AFOR AY.
YSO,OUNO KN EWVEINHO COS TGO
WREUT ABO IWAT S STRGE
STRE NGFOECE M BSEAUUCO S M
HF
ESHE T R OTF THEOO BK S ISO
ONPERSNDAL A TSHIAS WIN DEF
Y
NTMOA ME OF UNGSIOU YNO KW,T WHA
THID VEOND AT WHA I
TEESPRENTH IDN EEI ZEITGST TO
RTSO OE GIV ANENS IIDK LOOF O
MYIEXP EERNDENC AY MACPP ARO
O
LIMODENDNG A THE K LD INOFEIK
DYWEPOR MICSHAT REWE ONHA T
ONHA TT SUTET BEA YHINAT WCH
T
AGN.AI
ASIT WIK LET' 'SOT N 'ON D'
T
TFEELTHAUC MHAU BEC'SE I 'ME,IK
IUS JTHI TNKBO AUTDAHA TT YF O
WO
HT RLIG,OU Y K RW,NO IREMEMBE
O
H MWUC I GOTIP TBEEM REMR WHO
D WIAS
INATG.
OUDO Y WNO KWT IEAN?
LIEM I, R TBEEMRTHAINIM TE Y M
FELI.
BUTAV I H'E'TCH WAT IEDT TTHA
MAIM TES SN'I O DOT EL.
'ON D' LTEIK L TE IVINEO VHEID
ANEAY M R YLOU KHAWNO W IT
NE,AN OHEF O TURLE PASFES OME
TH
EOO BKONVE ERYEUT O THE.
IST THA ELYMI RRSEMEMBEHE TIK L
E
EHE T TNTATREMEOT NESRO FM
THAT V
EOID?
'THEY 'REMBYER EINRAARSS
E WATERTHHE TY E  WEYERKELI.WH
TRET SHYOMANNGHI M
KELI ITAS WEA REAYLL Y
IEA MN,HI TNKT IAS W JTUSN A
INGSTREINBEIM TE  PUSCAEPLEOE
E
T SREOR OFDYLR AEA, YOUNO KW
STMIFENIIK LE BONEYCEADN'TOU Y
OWKNOI CHEDNE TER TMSR  O
ND
THE FER TMTSINEMISET Y,UT B
TH
EERAS WIK LE FHI TSTINEMIS
BLOSPHEOEER PEREPL WEIN K
INTALKUT AGBONOOU Y KE LW,IK
OKAYBENG THISN IHE TAS PT
N'V'AL TTOTEELY BNE LIK GATREHA
FO.OM WEN
BUIK LE,OW H CANIKE W LE,OW H
HENCA TE B FRE GATOROM WEN
SILWHEEILLTI BNGOT, GHT,
YO
OWKN?
RIT,GHEN ESS.ALTILY
WENTHE T INGESERTI WAR PTCHHI
DIIDOT NNO KW A TUTBOTHAEO VID
S IS IHEATTH T?ET SUP
THSO PERN STIETNGP U THEID VEO
WAYITRNG C TOATREE K AD INOF
GO
VI FBEOROU YUY G
AS WOW LER BIDESE TSHIIK LE
WE
KED IRLIRHIS STEDOOIB VE IN
TH
OO RM.
.YEAH
WE MAKG OFT. I
AHYE.
I MN,EA I TNKHIHA TTH ATNOER
ONREASTE W IAND T ARI WTEUTBO
ETHATNCERXPIEE IS BECSE YOU
,KNOW AHE TRERETI MUL SEPLESID
TO
T THAO T THEXP EE.IEERNC
IT WAS A FEMEEC DIRR.TO
IT WAS AEEM FALP DHE TREERE
TONSF ONG YOUOM WEN ON PPSRO
KEMAUP SIG DETESN WRTEHAVEND A
E RFO MHEAT T TE.IM
THI KIN I WAS0 2 21, AND IAD H
JUEE BNKI WORNGS  AAOD MEL
YICWHHW, KOUNOES I DIBCREDN I
-HHARD KDEEADFDIN OE, LIK TSHI
ISY M IND
TRUSY.
'I'MKI WOR.NG
'I' AAN MQUNEINIK ' IET'S NOT
N.FU
'I' G NSOTUSMOLARO
'MOTOI GNGO TE B A.I'
ODPESURM.EL
'I'AV SGINY MON MEY BAUECSE I
SA
T WWHAPE HAPDNEN I8. 200
AND I WASIK LE, 'ON D'TTOAN WT
LIBAOV ME O ICKNTAR PTSEN
AUSHOEAVND H TOE TAK ACEER SVI
INOBRYST J
EA YH, IAS WEA RYLLCA S ADRE
MELINT FELE LIKHI TS
E
TCHEAHE SEN EETSSALTILYHI T
S
KE ILS AGRO EWP U WHIT YOU
,KNOW MY M WOMAS AR.RI WTE
MYAD D WAS AAI P
ERNT.
ISLW AAYSTND UERHEDOO TOFDE IA
YLIKEOU HEAVO TAVER YOU DAY
B.JO
EYTHER WEEREA TCH K YS,OUW,NO
O
I WAS LE, O GY,KA ISSUEHI TS
LLWIE B DY MOBAY J ANDN THE' I'L
REFIGUHAUT O W IT RLLEAY WTANO T
DO
SOLLH,EA AF OHA TAST WRU T
E
ICCRITNDEDIZ AEO PAMEPL C M TEO
N
OSOD RTF YW, KOUNO INK THI
TH WEAS ATA CERINTMO AUNF O
PONGTIRSIN FGE AND LOWEIK H
DAEOU Y B AAR PT OF TS,HIOU Y
N
IS,OW MTIYNOGISCNG THI
I FEATEL RYLL PIVTEROCT O OEFF
OMUCHNET SND AOW HUC MHUN F ITH
D HA ODN SETOM CREPADO TIK LE
FRE STIDAC BKF O A SRTHI
OR
TISHOONGH WITOM SE, YOUNO KW,
CRPY GFUPRO OUY G
IAS WIK LE IAI WTE MADDSRI FEN
HAON T VID.
THEYSK AED ME I HOW IEL FT
'A' I WSHYDAN DCEHE TAY W
I
BDIDAUECSE WIN HASAV
FUG .
ANDID DOU Y TEE FL ACKRIEDERFT
OTHATROU YT  FELE NCSIERKELI
HAATTH WY TTHEUG TH' IHTT'S ME
ARFE.
IT FELREIN SCE
I FTELLS AANDEO FITCH WHI IS
SO
ORTF WHY IAS W'N'AY SGIN
E
ALSO THE GS WHOHO I SITT IT W
H
KWEREDIN OF --, YOUW, KNO
BE IEUST FEL VERROY PECTTEIV
HEOF TER EXP TNCIEETH' I'ADD H
WI
T TTHHATOIR DECNDR A WHIT
ETHOS OERTHEN WOM AOM WENO ANDLS
PR OTIECVEF W IMYTEAND
POO CSTI T
IGALN.
HOW IAN WDTEO T SEEYSEL AND
FE WHI WCHLDOUOU YEA MNY B
TH
ITE WAN TDOL FEEOW P
FUERL.
'ID DN'TAN WTO T FEESMAL
'ID DN'TAN WT TOL FEE LEIK AL.I
UINNMAEQ
I WAND TO SK LAYOO IKE WORD
YSISTH SM.TE
IE, LIK YOU KNOAD HS THI
COEIFODILL FUL AYETSS MY BOD
AN HAD AAT GREIM TE ON SET
IKDAN LH, YEEA YOUNO KWHA W
T
WTHAT M,ASBEAYHA T WTVEAS E
PO ARNDHI I TNK THA TTTHA I
TINTHKT'H'E TSRUF O A L NOT
O G ON AATEP SARGE TEAN,NTUT BOO
A LOTF O THEAY WSHA TTUR O
BE
EFLISRE A OENBO A OUTUR
ATIENTYNDT WHAE WTOAN WT OW H
WET WAN TO SEE AND FLEEUT ABO
OUWHVEELS ASHIC WHYT IAS W
SOTAMP IORNT FOR MEO T AOLS
WR
EIN K ODFHE T FLUL
CERIPEENBO AUTHA WTT IYEA RLL
WA LEIKND AOU YNO KW,LS AO
SPEC WTHY IEFAS W DNDNTIA A
YWHT  ILTFEO S IORTANTOR F ME
TO PEE FLLEROWFUHES A T NAK
RLGIMUN  IA DEC SIVI
I ANME, INTHK WLEHORI TCKF O
TH
E BKOO IE LSIKHIOM SETHANG TT
WE SEE GLYERENALN OHE T SFAURCE
LI WE'RE SUS JT YINEEGROU
MAGSTRAR ' WE' JRETUSEE SGINN
YO IVITHN E O DEWEIK LE THE
SUPLEA T OREFK BHEOO ISHA TTOU Y
TGE IN YOU GETHE TNANT IER
L
GHTHOU OTSFHA TTIK LEHA WTT THA
EXENRICE ISIK LEND 'HA TT'S
'ATWH'NTS INGESERTI IBO AUTT,UTB
'I'E LSIK A H
RTEA.
'IT' LSEIK AAR HDTOIN LE
ALK
LIKE TY'H'RESEEC BA' IT' NSOT
YO
UOM CINDIMOFY YGRWN O BYOD
YE
E LTIK NOTET Y
R'U' GUS JTTIETNGAI PSH TDO
W
OR F AEW FOU H B,RSUTND A SEOM
D P OPLEOEERTH P APLEOERE
GLLTEINOU Y' YOU 'RENGEI
IFJEOBCTD,IEUT' YOU 'REINRYG
TO LOMEIK SOWEHL FEEOW PFUERL,
OWU YOKN
THATOU Y KWNO MELY RHIIOATNS
PWI
THGRNS ITAAM AT THATIM TE
ALACTUT FLYELHE TE SAM W.AY
IT WIMAS SOARIL THE TS WAY THAT
IEL FT AUTBOHA TT VEOIDND AHE T
ENNMEN THAT WASN OET S
WH WHAS TTHA I YNO KWAS WN I
LNTCORO INOM SES. WAY
IOUW KNO M IELODS TNHE
90S
'DID'TAV H AAY WF O DNGTAICTI
H
OUT.GEMASY THEER WENGUT PTI
ITASUS JTEF LT UPO T THE
MA
ZINE ANDTE WHADIRVE ERTO
WOW C CANMYATURE ITDE INT LE,
LINE MELF I CANON COLTRHA TT.
AN
HAD TTT FELEA ROOYLL G
FELLIT KE YOUW KNOT I ITEL F
I
TR CKEON.OL
IAHYE,N MEA THE THANGHI TE LTIK
IS ON THEER OTHID SE T OFHE
SCTH IES REEER ATSOM MENN I
EOO B WKNHE YOULI REAIT AZEWATH
F
HI TS ISY M PHAT TOER POW
MOY CONOL,' 'MD KINF O
ENPEDENDNT OEN MIK LEHEEN M
WH
OT WAN TS.HI
'IT'IKS LEIR THE DIRESEND A
GAYPLIN S TOOHA T WTTHAS IT THA
ATALREIZN?IO
KELI,OW H DSOE TTHA TUR TNO
G?ELFEIN
IEA MN, IHI THANK T'T' THE
ISESF O B THE LRRLUEDESIN
ESY ISORT OFLI REANGZIOU Y
TKNOWTHAA AS OU YNGIR GL I MY
20 BHI WCHY THE W,AY YOUNO K
B
Y OUVISLER EMYXP INCIEE A
IDEMOL VSYERCI SPEC.FI
'IT 'SNTRND IUSUTY, B IAV HE
NDFRIEWHS OK LOOAC B
IEA MNAY TWIRLO SFTSH WE LDOU
BOLKTA AU , UTYOOW, HOWHE S
FESKI LOONG BKAC ATEI BNGY M
IKTTIOKS ALLRAY TLOFT SWIND A
JA
LE GKEYL
AANHL.
I' 'VEETNEE L'' AAL TKUTBO IT
RFO0 1UT MIN.ES
Y.ACEXTL
YE.XI EST
ULI WO TLOD VEUMUT BO, N
I
IANME,  THI TNKTHA AOT LF O THE
X
CERIPEEN HADA AS  YNGOU
ARSPEONS AEL MOD,UT BO ALS WHIT
CTTEINRANNSIO IYSO PERLNA
E
WASIK LE,H O I''ECAU' 'M
AUNYO' IND'ESM D.ABIRLE
I'HEM THONE O WHEAS H T PEROW
AN INK THIHA TN ETVE MEN FTEL
AYATTH WHE T MEN TTHA I W
ASIN
INRATECTH WGITND A INK THI
ACOMLYAL S OEF I THEESTANSNC
WATTH ITERIUT ABO INHE TOO BK,
THTLM AOSEL FTIK LE TYER WE
I
LA RKEEC TINIMGOWIRHE P BERY
KI
ND OF DNGOI TSEHE LEIK
PESRDIES TFUCTL BNGHIS IAUECSET
FE LEIK OHHI TNG YOU
TIBEAUIRLFU GE LLIK S SHE'H'S
THNE O I LEIKHE S''UA ACTYLL
LAASEMCUE NGTI ME  SINOMYWA
E CABEUSESH THE PEROW HEER
BE
SUSCAE'H'IR DSESN EEDVE
TH NGHOW L IKOOAC BK AND'M
,LIKE OH I WUA AASCTYLL S
UNYOG.
TADUL AND YOUNO KW, THEERAN
ATSITUASNIO WHE T PEROWAM DYNIC
WA VERFE DYIFNTREN THA WTHA I
GHTHOU
SO YH,T' THAS'S RTF OAR P
T
OF THE RIOELEVATNF O BRRLUED
ANELISNDND A CGRTHAINY M
REIPONTISHHAO T TEO VTID MY
RYMEMO OFHA TT V AEOID
HNW
ITS''OUSOAL YNO KW,
ESREPRVETAENTIF OHE TVO E
N
Y OF MCSLIPOTI TTHA WAS SHUC A
HARDO ND E TENATTH S
NCTEE.
'THAT 'SD.OO
LYOBPRABOR F AIT LETLGE LON
R.H
E THENERE THE''UP A S
ERCR
NCPYEE IINENIDT  THEK. BOO
I  AANTHNOER T TNGHI BKOO
IESSAK TEOU Y IORONT W
SLD
MTHATTOS OF US' DO'TAV HE
TCEACSSNDO ' IT'SIN K ODF
E
R AFTED URBLRE ANELISND A O LOT
U
YESCCSOU END UP INIK LRD WEEI
VIUA SIT
ONTIS.
YCANT JOUUSEL TL I MN,EAS THI
IS AS LESL WEL KWNNORY STO, BUT
THENE OBO AUT THE 2005,0O THO S
P
T A SRTS
AM GE.
S ATTH I WCHSU A
RDEI.
ORSTYE LIKT WHA IST THAOR WLD
AN
DOW HO TIF D WREFENTENOM
VEBEHAN IT THAOR W?LD
UM,
EA YH.
WELLHA TTSS EAYS I C
LEALD
SATRAN AIOCTNS E ANDN OERXCPTF
RITAN INHE TIAUA GRD
F IOU YEA RTHD ATHE TNHAT'S
WH' 'REREM FE
INNCG.
I WASYEA RLLESNT IERDTE IN
ININIGSTATG MY OWN JTGMUDEN
F
WONME AND T HOWYHEATAV NIGE
EMSYST POFS EROW INAR REG TDSO
SMENCACIPEFIY,LL YOUNOW IYN M
YO TNO KWREHE IOU CLDRI WTE A
OLWHE BKOOUS JTBO AT TUTHA
EDCALLE LIKRIIC VTOS'A'CRET
GI
OH, S.YEEAGRTHA CCTRAERN I THE
AHYE.
'SHE'S AEAL FEN.ER PSO
BU YOUNO KW, W IASER INT
TD
IN I IEA MN,HI TNK PEOEPLIN KD
OFEIK DOT THA INHE TIR
MA
.IARRGE
SOMES HAVEDSRI FENHO W
U
,KNOWAR MRYODOM SEB WYLTEAHYND A
ERATWHEV'HE TRE 'SLLIN K ODSF
NE
IOTIGOAT BNSUT IN THE
RYDUINST, I'T' VYERPE SFICIC
BE
USE A ASNWNNK UNO,OD MEL
'YOU'ASRE B,ALICLYOU KW,NO
TH'E' WOM WENINHO KDF ORE A
SENTUT OO TTI CASSNGO TEC RIT
ROTHEOU YNG MELODS TO
NTESSE GLLIAYUT O WHITHM RICDON
USDAN JTE LIK WTA SNDHM THET A
AB T ALENDIK L TEY'H'D KREINF O
PIHONGO TAV H SEXH WIT Y,OUUT B
ONKELI HTHTLESY T  JEYUSOUNTWA Y
TOND STA TEX NTOM THE AAK ME
TH
K LEMOOL. COO
IT 'SNY, BUTT' 'TYPRS ET DKAR
DAN YW, KOUNOT' I 'S'T' AP STE
AW
M FAYROHE TEF JEYFRTE EPSIN
KI
ONDFLD WOR TO BEAL TOTLY
NEHOST ANDS A AOWS NGIV LINN I
NE
WK YOR IIT CY, SEE I' DON
'T
LYREALOO G TCLIG NHTUTS,UB B
'ERTHE'EES BN AFE DIFEWNTRE F
DI
T ERFFENSMEMONTHE WRE' 'VE
DTCWAHEHE TSE GIK LE OUPROSF
UVERYE.ERNDAG
VE CLELYARYOER VY OMGUN WEN
IWALKNIT WIKH L OENEUY G' WHO'S
THE PAR PTYRMOROTEND A TNHEOU Y
HEOWKN TEA WUYHYLT GSIN KDF O
JOND A I'T'AT REL.ED
SOAL,HE T'R'EB CSELTYRI
EN .
E'THERS TSHILE WHOIN KDF O
ETMARKDRO AUNHI TS ANDOU YNO K
NAS ANK UWNNO MELOD YOU' DO'T
TGE PD,AIUT THEYEN ESS
AY
HOST ANE DIN
F I' YO'REOU Y KWNO AOR WNGKI
IDEMOL Y LNA'O' NREOTGAK MIN
ATTH MHUCON MEYOU YR''UN HYGR
HTRASTIGNDP U A YOUO GO THE TSE
H
NDGSIN A KHE TYHAWNO WT
'EYTH'OIRE D.NG
'EYTH'IKRE LEE  COMTO NOB AND
NOUYO K TW,HEHO WLEIB VE ISIK L
A
TVEHA WTEOUR Y WANTRI DNK
WHEREV YT WOUANND AO AOT L
ODOF M BS ELGO TAUECSESTY HEJU
WAEA M AL THE TYHEET G A
LINK DLERUHEND A THEN TR'Y'
DVIINTE T C TOHEBLUND TT'H'
SO
RTKEF  OLIHE WNHE TSELT WEAHY
E
NOM CINE TOLA PYO S I HAD
ENPEEXRITHS CEWIHATRE WHE YOU
,KNOWT F IELXT EMERELY
MFUNCOE TAORBL SOMODY OWH
YONO KWAD HOT NAD HAS WLW ASAY
RYIK L CARLEACRA TNS
ONS
ANDHO TSEER WE NOTER VYAR CLE
HEDAN TN THE THETH OER PTAR OF
THAY EATSSNS I AIEXP EERENC I
HA
DIT WHHE TOW N FEITUGIV JOE
MLOWEANAYALSIIVUG FITEHO W
AUCODEDAN FNDINHEDCE TOL WFR
OF
AL WLEE STRT, A HNDE W
LLNTSEIATEY SINALGON MEYM FRO
TH MANAYALSI P
PLEOE.
'I'SRE P HYTTERIORBL S TRYTOHE
MAIAYSN GERNMT.EN
ETHRE PDESINTAS W EALENSSTI
LYO
WINRKGHITIM H TO LPT THA
HA.EN
'I'AT GSRE
AVOU Y H'E'D RTEAT, IRE THE''
AOO BK CALD IHI TNKONIL BLI
DOLI BARIL DONLAOLRHA WLER
INMESOTH
'IT'ST' IR'S LYALZY CRA, BUTOU Y
KNY MAG MANEROT G AL CALIK LE
OH AND IAD HMOUS JT TOD VEIN
P
T.TMAREN
WORKT THA BAV HES BEDUGND AE LIK
WAS TALOTLY I NOTAS WGIV LIN
HEIN T VAS ET ALAILGEWA INDT S I
WAEW N TOORHE T W.LD
00 2SO5,LA D0OL A IRSSOT LF O
MO
YNEE  HUGOUNTF YM,,ES U
AN WHE TYEER YIK LE,EH,EA H
WJUSTTSANOU Y TO CEOMO THE T
BPESURLOWND A W IASIK LE, WTHA
O
OU YEA MNOM CEO THE TER SUP
ABOWL M MNDYAGANERT AHE TIM TE
WASE LIK TRUSTE? M
'I'S LOO CL JEIKIEAMOX FXL WIL
BE TREHE LONAEORDRIIC DAPE LOIK
OTEB CRELL WSILOWE B H DUC MH
O
UNK THIHE TY GOT PD?AI
ILD WOUE LOV TOW KNO TOV LE
OKN
.OW
N, MIEAO I D KWNO TT,HA YOU
,KNOWT' 'S PLIUBCDEC ROR TT
LIHE TREE WERIAAS BQUTSHA T
TE
ZE SREEIFRD OM YOUNO KW TSEHE
RSACTO ''NDESOM ATE WHARVEHA TT
GWEREROTSIF F.JOM LO
'I'TH WSOR
IT.
EAI MNT JUSHOO T SW UPET  ATH
SU BOW LIKH. YEEA
WE I DN'I'T CEAR
BO AUT
BAFOOT.LL
,, SOUMOHY W DIKOU Y LEER CHET A
ETHRO WEN MNGOM?TS
,OH IE HAVO N IADEHA W WTAS
GGOINN O A, ATLL SO IN' WAS'T
PEVENINTERENDANG DT THAHEAS W T
OTLL RREAYAR BIZRE TBONGHI A
THTEE ESINNSCTRAIO L ISE,IK YOUT
,KNOW DOU Y'O'UA ATCTYLL HAV
O
DO
HA TT.
LIKE 'AS WN'T I WA'NG BTEI
TOLDO T CRERHE OINNY ATH BGUT
WAASATWH WESNT IERNGTIN I
H
OFHE TSE ENCERXPIEEAS W WGCHATIN
WHOTH OER WENOM L SEIKAW
UNPOOPRT AIEITSIT CNDAP OIZALED
EMND AAS WIK LE,Y OKA
IK E
GTHISIO OUYBV WLYUSTSANO T HEAV
FUAUBETIEN WLOMDRO AUN LE,IKOW H
CA I PLAARY IHI TSOMONT S
G
LA
ERRG?
AND I THI TNKTHAT A C A
TAN
TPOINYN I MIF LE, W IIKAS L IE,
O
DULEV NERATO  DTH
E,WHANIL I'M YOU KWNONG DOI
PA
OSID P FTSOOOR TEPATHSTT THA
ARWN O BEDYHE TAM SEYP TE OF
NSS ELYTIENAL ANDBE MAY
HET
SATRAN IIOCTNTTA S LI M BLEITEOR
EACLR.
SORTF OIK LEY MWN ONGUD JGI MYO
NOWNT IZENAERLIOG MDISYYNND A
SOAL,OU YW KNOD KINF OE LIK
GIZALINOW HOW H WELL AXI ESTE
ALTHHEGHOU T'R'SN ACUND UER.IS
T
IKOF L IEHE W YN SOUAY T
CTANTRSAOTNSIO NLE CART I HPSEL
ER UMEND WANSTDASTHA W OOI GNGN
HYOURECDEA BSEAUHE T'S A LOT
RE TOFHE''IK LEOS AL' ITT'SOT N
EQUITNCIO VLE BUT ITSN DOE''
FE
AF SE.
LIKE Y' DOUON 'TWN'HA WT'OIS G
O
NAP HPEO T YOU' DON 'TWNO
'ATWH'XPS E OTEECD. YFOU
I'SIK LE ALL REA WYRDEI
ATSITU TNIOOINAL FL  ATONDHE T
ROTHENG THIS I YOUAN C''
NEYARSSIL' 'DI RMEAO INGNTT. I
ANUYO CEL TL ME IF IHI TSE TSRU
OR
OT N.
CYOU'A'ES NTECRISALYY RELN
TH
THE OER.OM WEN
-HMM.MM
T'KELI 'SHE ' IT'S HARTO TLEL
IN AOT LF OHE TACNT IERONTIS
HTHAT WPEAPNNHE YOUAL FLO INT
TIRELA BSHONIP TWEETENHEOM WEN
LIRE AHE TYEN FRI?DS
EARHE TY CTOPEOMTI?RS
HAKELI W HTOW TRE AYHE P
YG
OFFACH OERTHN ISE THE
SI?IOATNS
YE
IEA MN I AYUACTLLDAN WTEO T
WR AMOE REHEUTBO T.NT IER
THAT I HADIT WHHE TTH OERAN WOM
,
TELIMI IAND D RDLIEAZE IT WAS
BED
USCAEE WER WET SORF O F
ON THEER EXP,NCIEESOU YNO KW
GBEINT AHI TSE LIK CB LUOR
GUESRE TSHE'' AEIT LTLIT BF O A
H
FGIN OIK LEHO WSEID SERE AOU Y
ONDE IKANH, YEA INK THIHA TT
'ATTH'OMS SHIETNG IN MEAON H
Y
TOE MHE TK BOOS IOR ME AUTBO
TIRELASSHONIPIT WHTHEROM W
EN
ER ODTHOM WENITHA TN N.S  IME
INET A ONT POIDAN WTEO TAM NE
YEVERSS EAYFT AERIK LE IEA MN,
LLSIBACAY TOUK ALABY M, MOMOU YI
OWKNEN FRID INIG HHLCH SOO
FAEN WUSOM YHA WT'O' HVEAD AN
M
CTPAE.N O M
LIKE IO D THI TNKHATHA TT CLDOU
EEVEHA B TNHE ALTIT TLE FHEOR T
R OKBO OE  SINOMY.WA
UYOSLW AAYTOPP
BRO T A
TY
MFOR TEO CCHATOP U TOU Y
.TH
'A'Y. OSKA
ION' 'TNVEW KNO' 'M DNGOI
.
E'THERS ARE THES''T.POA IN
WEINI , T'ITK 'SHE TWEY RE
SISTH I AKY RIS THI TNGO DO I
TH
K BEOO WCHHIS I TO LIKEIK L
EH
EHI T YNG WTEROUT ABOOU YR
TR SR OTOR OFHE WSTYON U TAR
.TO
IFMMCOODRS YYOULMFEL ATOSND A
KD ANASEEO PPLT' 'D HSARO TE B
SORTICF O RNDH ASSUC SCELFU AND
EOKAS PEPLO TAB INHITOU YRIN MD
R
EE FLTHYM SPAICETHA TTEE FLS
ALIKEIS RNG TKYHIO T
DO.
DIDOU YVE ENK TRHIBO AUTHA TT
ANIK LE P HOWPLEOEE LIK
ILL
FTHEYORLEE S FRYOR
ME?
NO,HE T'ON W'EET F SOR FOR M
E
USCAE A IMIC RHND A OR
WH
EREV.
I MNEA IN' DI'TRI W ATENY OF
E
SAESYSE LIK LKING FOR
HYMPSYAT
RO WTE TECMHE BSEAU IAD H
QU
STIESONBO AUTY M OWNXI E
E
MAND OY CICTRONADONTISND AY M
OWNE LIFT THAAN WDTE
TO
OREXPL M AENDRYBEAY T TOOM CEP U
WITHOMEWE ANS,RS AUT BSTO LSJU
HAIK LEND A IGAESNVTIONTIND A
A RORECD OF TTHANV ITITIESGA
ON
ADNSS E,AY T BUTNHEEO PEPL
ULCODOFIN KD ,OU YNO KW,EL TL M
H
Y TATHE WTHA TY TBONKHI A
HIEES THESNG WY' TNHE 'RETHA
HEEAR TUG TIRHOS.HT
AWHAT TREOLIRHE PICS?
DATOHE TY OAK MEHEF TSE
LANDHAEIK WS DTOEAYT I SBO AUT
H
WELDOR WEIV LE IN TOUTHA Y
CAN
NE BAI PD TOO GN  OAIOAC VAT
AND YOU KNO LWEIKHE TAY WS TTHA
'
'MFDIN OIN TRYG TO TCKE AKBA
O
ANRONTL  MD IOUN,EA YNO KW
WH YOU SAYMO COMGFYDIIN
YO ILFSE,'T'IK LE I YEA HROU
TBU AT THEAM SEE TIM MY
ENPEEXRIM FCEROEDLU BRRES LINO T
INDOGHA TLS FTEE LER VYTEIK I
FEE LSIKHE TAM SE.HI TNG
IT 'SKIE IKTANG A.HE CCK
NOUYO KT WW,HAO D YOUEA MN LEIK
'ERTHE'S M AWHENOMT ENOU YR''
WH I TTNKHI I LEE FLSNEIK I
TH
OO BK.
E'THER 'SOM MTENHE WNOU Y
TUAL MAKHEE TIOEC DISN LE,IK
ULY WHWOID  WHYOULDUT I P YOU
KN W,HY IOU WLD WREA AIN BIK
I
FORODOM SEBE' EYLS 'SINI
CO
ANMPY?
IGI M W AHTSOLEL DORT I FYS MFEL
STPOED ONY MWNNS IGRTAAMND A
TH
LS FATEEFUOW PER BL,UTT' THAS
IKTNO L ETHE E.ND
ILLWE, TNKH' IT' JSTUSBO AUT
COLRO AUTBOAV H MGINEOR
LNTCOROS AOD MEL AND AS A
MMODNDYIT A MSI UNGY BYOD
D
WTHATUT,AY B' D IONK'T .OW
TIF IVEEL RIEER PSOW I, MNEANE O
OFHEUE QIOSTNS T OFK BHEOOS I
SORTF OIK LE WTHA ISOW EMP
T
IST I FANCI SAL?CEUCSS
IS IT A FLIEENG IST I
LMLFFUILSTEN IT IE? FAM
IS IT INEE FNGLIDAN WTE IST I I
N
NOTNGEE FLIAN WDTEIK LEHE WRE
WHY
T WATHAMPS I ENTEROWME R
MEAN
'I'H SSU' I AT' WS ADOR IEA H
RO
UC MHHE WN ITES COMO TEN WOM,
CIESPE ILYALNOP PREUL CTU ANDN I
MYWN ENCERXPIE
'MAIEIK W CT,AN WEUS JTO G
NDCKBA A LEIK CAN WE DINEFET THA
SOT'H'T' TSHA 'STOR OF ONEF O
THRAR LGEIOUE QSTTH INSN
EBO
.OK
AINEI WRD WAYHE T POS MTLEROWFU
ES IYN T BOOHI WRY ECHVEEON
ABLKTAS ICT OUWHHEISH  T
ELT
HTHATDPEAPNEOUO T YHENOU
WE
NG YREOU T AERNDNHEUL SHO WD
E
LL TTHA S
RYTO?
IEV NERW KNO M HOWEOHUC PEPL
.KNOW
IHAN,EA ' THE TTO SRYTHA
WA
T OSNUTHE C
WAHYE,L'E'L TELT I IN VER
IEBRF,TUT B I WT'H'ER ISNT
G
MOTHE AR CSTLEIK LE AOT L OFT'
ROTHE I IT BLYICASALEL, WL,
U
ATELLRYUM SMAF OT'T I I 'SRDEI
ERFO M TO I DO
BUT BUTT I ISHE TOS ME LTIK TO
T' TMEH'S LIK A TNGHIT THA
ENPPEDHA T ITOS S BAD IHA TTT
WO LDDEA YOU TTAO KETR CONOL
OF YROU OWNOD BY CTYMOOMDI
DEHAYIN W LVETEREIKT' 'SUS JT
O
RO WNG
HA TT.
,YEAH I ATITHT E M'ET L'ELS T
LH
RY SETO
E' 'REOT N LEIK SGAKPEINN I
IN
ESREFENC
,AHRE THEAS W AGRHO PTO
HR
SHWHO  MOTEN WHE IIKAS W L19E
ASIT WD KIN OF ARE PYTT
TAMFCOORE SUATI T AONNDNHE
HET WENN O TO PLIUBSHTI MULEPL
BOS UNGHE T IGEMAS AND MY
GAIKGIN LEEARSATER
EYT JUSO G UPND A H'E'UC S AH
N
--S AT' 'SAP HNIPENG T ANDNHE
ORKELI S,RY I IEA MN,'T' A
Y,TRUL KOU YW,NOT'S FNYUN TTHA
UYO SAY TTHA I'T' SOLYLE CAR
WRAU BECTH ASET  ITIE ME YOU
,KNOWIR F A OSTF,LL IUR TDNEO T
KELI TEGHE LALMYS STE ANDRI TED
TO,AYKA OY,E LI'HA WT'YS M
GAL OTECERONTI H
ANDHE TREAS WO N WAYHA TTON ANY
O
DHIAY S T ISSRO WNGND A
ERTHEAS W NOTI JUS TCEREHE AND
ENTH ICT ALLUAY TNEURD TO THE
RIEXPENDCEEN AOW H IID DT'N'NTWA
MAETH IOSGE T BEUT OHE TRE AND
ALNEO N OEL FT IIK LEWAT S
THAT'' AOO GDNT POI TGAT HALEYLL
KELI YOU SNEIGD THI R,EAELSE
BU YIK LEAIROU B'OU Y'REO S I
DI
'D'N STIG THESEEL REA
.OH
, R
HTIG.
.YEAH
I DN'TIN FD THEEL RSEEA
POYIANTLLGEN A AAYNT MD SBEOL
OR IT WASGE FOR
WILBLRO PBARNEY VE KWNO BUT
I
ANME,EA YH, NE.
DYNOBOHTHO TUGHA TTHA TT W
ASVE
AR CRYLEUT CHE WNT WAS
HAEVINENG N WENHE ID KINF O
LIKENE TUR M TDOY FLOWENDRS A
A
E, LSIKEY H' DO'TUY BHI TS
OKBOTE WHARVEVE EWAONRYE
E
NO,OO TKHO TSEREIC PTUS,O S I
'DNDI'EET FLE LIK ITASAR CLE
.I
HAKE TTAS WSSHE T EAYAS W
EACLR.
IHI TNKT I WASEI RECSDVE AUCH
T ENWH IP.NTWE U
WASRI P IEDNT NNEWOR YK
MABUNEZI,  ITHI TNK ITAS W
IVRECEED ASNG WRO
.YE
LEPEOPEL FTY VER LE,IKH, O W.OW
ISTHUY GS I AN --HAND A WVETER
TBUT IUS JLS FTEEOR MLYAL
OUTREOUSHA TTOM SNEEOOU CLD
IASEESNTYLLIK LE ARI TCKOU YNG
RSPEON INHI TPL CSOM WELETYRDEI
ATUSEPND TOAK TGINHE T
CTUR BESEOT TISLYAL DESSMIIV
OFHE TM ANDHE TN YRSEAAT L
ERLI
N WKEHE THE WNY'H'REOR WTH
INMESOTHG CEOMAC BKNDSHUB PLI
I
OURCTES A YFOUAKND ME AON T
EY MOFON OFFF O ITOT NCTON CTA
LN
K' IT'S AGEUT ORA LSOUEIK
YOUROU SLT IEE F SLSORA OUT
S
ATTH TTHA COUAP HN.PE
N MIEA IEA HROU Y BUT YOU KWNO
FOE MT THA WAS ANXPER
N.
I HAD A OON TFHA SMEDRO AUN I
TH
IGHOUTCT AED AINER CTA. WAY
IN' DID 'TTEROCT MYSF.
IAN WDTEO T I HREMPSS AS HE
DI
DISSMSE M
T EEDRINVERAR HDE TOIN KDF O
IMSES H.IM
I YOUW, KNO I DID THOEAK TSE
ESCTPIUR
E,OR F MIDT I ' FEEL.LE CAR
ITTI SLL'OE DS'TEE FL TALOTLY
ELI FTOM CICPLIT IN T
SHAMROE ATDUN I AO  ANDLST TINHA
ESITI Y WRTABE OUAP PAZARZI
LI
KE THEEA LAT RSTELLEABNG THI
,YOANNE YW KOUNO W
NHE I
PUDISBLHESSHE T EAS IAY WIK LE,
'ON D'HIT TNKNYO'SON GNA
HIKELI TAU BSECSE IAS WUR S
ETH
ATT WIN KD OF, YOU KW,NO
ER EMYXPNCIEEP UNT IT TOHAOI P
A
HAS TTEEO PPL NAD HOT BNEE
SY
TIATMPHEH WCITHO TSE TSEHO
GSTHINVENHOUGY  THHEDHA
N
TOUN I P THELIUBCHI WCHAS W YOU
,KNOWNO AERTHT I WY VASER
AGCOENURGIN IADLR ADYEAOR ST
OF ATTRIEN0,UTBO 5RD0 00WO
F
THE BK,OO BUTT IN' HAD 'T
.
ITAD H'N'IN KD OF DENOVND A
ST
TTEARD EDIUT BT I WAS
RE
LYAL EGIOUNCRA TNGOE HAV
.
EPEACO GUT O IOHE TLD WORND A
TSEETHAE LIKNGRI WTILD COUA BE
DIMERE WUMHE YOU KW,NO AST LTEA
PELEOU CLDHI TUT ANKBOHE T
ONESQUTIST THA W IAS POSG IN
A
YY,OUNO KWHA TT W I
ATUNMMICOMGIN SHIETNGND A AO
ATY WATH, YOUW  KNOVEGAE M
COL.RO
N, MIEA I TNKRI WNGTIHE T
K
'WE'RE TKIALNG CBO AUTTRONOL AS
O AANCTFOLON CTRNDO  TKIFRY T
TTOCKE AKBARRY  MNA
IVATE.
AHYE,T' 'NTS INGESERTI YHA TTOU
YS'OU Y'OTRE NNGOO LKIOR
SYECHYAT BSEAU IHI TNKHE T
ONREAS EHA TTAYSSATES RONEDO S
MUECS I BT SEAU IEESTJU F ILS
ESGUS.
ITUS JTEE FLSL REA LEIKOU YR''
NOOUOU Y Y PUT IT OUTRE THE IN
IN ALL CHE T OCLIREFER INTLNA
TSOUTHGHHA TTOU YAD H AUTBO TTHA
IOTUSIATLU INNCEENGDI FNGLI
CIMPCOLI
DANO ST IUS JTVE ENHHO TUGR YOU
X
CERIPEENS EREME
LYPA
ARICRTUL
''IKOT N LIL AE MONLIPL PEOE
HA
HVEADHA TTIEXP EERE.NC
IT''TI SLLEL R BABATLE
AUEE
YBEVERY'O'N BSEE INIT STIUAON
WH TEYHE FLEE CITPLOMIC
R O
'THEY 'VE APEOOD OUNRODY TRHE
D'W KTNOT'F I I 'SIRHE FLTAU
OR N.OT
,SOEA YH,BE MAYHA T'T' WHY IT
WASECEID.VE
L, WSOEL IEA YH,EA MN,GA AIN I
EWROTHE TSS EAYOR ST OFO T LAY
MYSE,LF BUTLS AOO TAV HETH OER
PELE BEBL A TEO E LMIXANE
I
SEVEN IAYNHE TOO B LKEI' I'M
PRNNGOA LAOCIM MY
CTRANTDINSIO, YW, KOUNO
USBECAIE  INK THIOU YW, KNOT' 'S
ALSOEN A TINCDEY AV HEF O KD
OF
LEIKXPVE ORE WUROSECHHI FOR
ERBETTORR O W L HSEASED T MEO
VEHE TE  LIFV'I'AD HOUUT B Y
KN
Y,OW'H,EA I 'MYERESNT IERDTE
SINTORF OIK LG BEE INRYVE
RNEHOSTTHHEATR ANND AIN TRYGO T
EOKEMA PEEEPL FL AINER CTAAY W
USBEC' IE'OTM NOTALE SUR H
ELFEUT ABO ATH OLLF EES
.INTHGS
THE'S A TT TRE' 'S
ROOMICNT MTEN WNHE YOUAL TK
T ABOUETINYOURNDUS HBA
ECCORRUTY,TL BT' 'S LEIK AS.
NTMOMEHE W H' IT'T'S I 'SBEAY
'I'IMS H
T'EYB IN'S OW ETMP.MEERNT
I'O'LL RTEANOY KT' ' JSTUS
ICMARONTUT B WE NHE HANMECOS
DN
LID KESS ELYTIENALUS JTD KIN
OFUT PSIMSEENET BWE YOUND A
OPPELE WHO TEE FLYHEE HAV A
GHTO Y.OU
NCAOU Y JTUS LEIKAL T AKUTBO
IT' 'SLYERITALIK LEP STOOM SNEEO
OMFR PTIUTNGT' 'S AY VER
TEREINGTOM MENHEN I T
COTEX OFHE TOOK.
LIWAS  S AKETEOMTY PAR IHA TT
WAE WE WEROT BHRE THE
ND A
BOSOMEED ADYSK POR F ATUICREND A
KELI KIN OFE LIKUT P TIRHED HAN
KELI TSHIIK LE LTLERIN FGE
CA
R OMEVE HEERN OS THIID S
E.I
WAS' DO'TAY ST THA ATL LIT
EDR
K.UN
AAHYE,AS IND WUS JE, LTIK OH
,EVATEROU YNO KW,ND A IEA HRDWH
HI SAYIK LE NOUO TINCHG ANDHE T
YGUIK LE IMMIATEE LLYIK
DRISDPE H.AN HDS
I'IKM L I OE,H''ORO S SHI,RY W
I
OU WLDE HAVEV NER DONFYS MEL
TO
E BES HONCH WT,HI ION D''
TH''BLRO PBA A NYOT
OO GD
THIN
H WIIS W IASOR M TEHEE TYP
PE TONOHAAY S TTAU BECO D
KTHIN AS ALI PUBSO PCERNDNA AS A
AN WAOM IOR STEEF O FLIK LE NO
L'M LI PKEUBERPRC OP
ATD
THSOMEGINAV H AEICOM CPLEDAT
FEOUG INARAN INDT DHE T IAS PT
DHAAT DEDEN MHO W WEER LER VYEIK
E'S'OTS GS  THIESHSN DOE''EED,
UNO KER EW,NTNTNY A IIOJEERCT
N
LW ID ASAYHTHO TUGHA TTAS W
VECTES RPEL.FU
,SO KOU YW,NO I THI IFOU Y
DWOUL MSK AOR BEEF HEE HE DADON
H
OU IAT WE HLDAV SIKDAI L I
DOL
'N' IIK LE WTNHE MENE LIK
TLIKE HYHEEAV TOANAN C H
EL
THEUA SITONTI ONY  MTN OWBU ALL
OF SDEUDN I WASIK LE,H, O W.OW
'H'SESNT IERDTEN I PINTEROCTG M
E
ANGUSD INIS HEL RHIIOATNS IN
TH
LD WEORE LIK WHOIS HE  A AS,
YO KISW,NO CTE WHIAL ME KFDIN O
A BIGUY GO TE LIK PTEROCT ME
D
ITOR FAC LKF OTE BET WTER RM
AO
OTAS W HY MIR GDRILFENITEA RD
DANHE SAS WE LIK WOWT THAT THA
ASRTPA WNDOT H A L W IASEIK
YES I , WAH. YSOEA
IAS W LKIOONGOUT A YRTA INSAMGR
TFOBEREVESHI E,NT AND IAS W
KITHINIKNG LOS AELM ATSN A
UMDEADNDO T MY BYODE LIK THE
KISF O PSTUICRE' YO'VETE POS
D
LYLATETHIK LE NAPRE EG
TNE
NAPREGY.NC
ETHGN PRECYANAB BYIE SERSHE T
PRNANCAS BYRENGEETFDIS,ER SIE
AN IAS WDE WONNGRIUT ABO THE
REIPONTISHO T W TTHHEERSEHO
REREWE F
NGEI.
I MN,'HE TRE 'SEIKEA A B
L
URPICTFE OAKOU Y N
AEDND
NAPREG.NT
WHOOE DSHA TTT OM MENOU YR
LIEEL RATO TTHVE ERY YGIN'O'
R
INITG?
'IT'S LEOU YROD BNG BYEISE U
DN
AL T AOT.LY
I MN,EAHE T'R'S AEW F
STBREAGEDFEINREIC PTU
US,AH JT WTHAASHA TTABT OUE
FOU?YO
IT WAS ARI TPEC BSE I
WAS
SHFINIGINHE TK BOOS WL.EL
SO IAS W W ATIRINGYUTBO M
OY
TAND WREHE AASEN MOMTRE WHE I
IKSWA LE, WL,EL IAN C''UB PSHLI
TH BOO BK NAUECSE IOWAV HE TO
AITWREUT ALLBOANRE PGNCYND A
HBIRTSEEC BAUHA ' LIKT' TEHA
'S
EVNGYTERHI TUT B I TNKHIT'H'LL
JUST HEAVOE BTH ANOK. BEROO
I W DOTERIUT ABOHE TTH BIR MF O
O
N IN THEAS LY.EST SA
I SIO CURBOUS A HUTOW
NAPREGSY NCWAOI GNGO TEC AFFET M
LKTAUT ABOK LACF OTR CONOLIK L
O
WUEAKP UVE E A DRYAYNDR YOU
DYBO ISUS JTOI DNGOM S
HIEG
COMPTELYREIF DFE T ANTN'REHE'S
YTEVE'NGHI'S YOI GNGONOU D'' K
K'HA WT'OIS G ONGNIK LE YOU
LYREA'ON D'DT A'OU Y' JRETUS
ONDFNGRO GWI AND EINRYVETH'G'
CHNDNGGI AUT B IND FOUT
ACEALYAL RYLL IEA RNJYLL EED
IT
E'ODYBY'XPS EEIEERNC
IT WH
NAPREGSYNC IEA RYLLREIF DFE,NT
TBU I AYUACTLL HPEELD
ME
ECAPPRY TEIA M
DYBO.
TRTUS IT KDINF OIK LE LET GOF O
ROCONTLND AAY SIK LE, OYKAHI TS
G THIN TOWKNSSHILES VSEWS KNO
TTTBEERENHA M AND I HE TO
SOF OAK TE THEASSEERNGEA ST
LEAND  HTHT AT
PEAPN.
SOUC MH OF L MY HEIFAS BNEE
REONGTI T MYOD BYA AS OO T
L
AND YOUW KNO AL TOO TO GEERAUANT
LOLIBITYS A A TLOO T
TEARGUANAN FEIN SALCI,CEUCSS A
I
NK THIHATOUW, KNO IT DN'I'
E
EL LEIK TLOO PLATIARCUNYRL I
BIH ANDN IGN PRECYANSEEC BAU
IT RDUIEQRE MEO T LET GO OF
GIMANAT TNGHAL. TOO
IT WAST  JUSINGET SOMNGHI ON
IT
OWS N AND TN,HE YOU KENW NOEV
MOO SN I THEN IHA TT LTAS
ESLL RY,EATLON HES TY,HE
BITES MENOMT FOR MEAS WHE T
BIE RIDHA T IT TEAKIT WHY M
HUNDDAN ARIY M FDD ENANT JUS
SOFNG BEIBL AE TO AATREPPCI
Y
IOD BYS AHI TNGT THA TESAKE M
HROTHUGIF LE,HI WCHS IHA WT A
BO
DY I
MM-H, THI WCH BHEEEASRETFNG
ESCTPIUR IHA TTAS WTI PARYLACURL
THBONGKI AUTAU BECTSE I IS
LIOU YROD BY AS AL TOOE LIK
ANATTH MOTY MAVRSHE H
PERI BCEEND IUTN AAL TOT
LYDI
TERFFENAY WIK LEOB NY'O'
YING N I'ODOBY'AYS PORGIN FS
ITUT B ITAS HO TORO D WK,OU Y
OWKN, AND IUE GSST' '
S
AISUSTNGNIIF LEND AHAT WAS
FEEABRST WINEDGUA AASCT
YLLA
KCHUNHA TT WAS INT THAT LAS
T'SO I 'SHANYUN TOUT YR''GAY SIN
IDIT D'N'OR WNGTIK MIBUIS WE T
'ERTHE'HIS TLL RSEAZY CYRAHI T.G
ONI D'' KWNOOW HY MANEO PEPL
ADVEHA HHI CRELDNR OAD H TSHI
ENPEEXRI Y BCEUTR YOUOUAS BRETS
WAOU YP UO FDEER YOU
HD
LIKE TYHEE ACH T ANDYHE HTUR AND
YOUE LIKLD W IOUMYIN FD LFSE
ALKELI W
NGKI.
LIKE A ZBIOME TOEE MTY MY BAB T
E
C MEDYLDHIND A IT WASHI T
S
LYREAL BIZREIEXP EERFENC O
H,,KE O' 'MOT NN ION C
OLTR
.HERE
LI'HE TRE 'SREHE ARE TNGHIS A
T
RKT THAE HAV KTEPAN HUMNG BEI
S
ONHE T PNELAT AND TT'H'SHA TT
MAENCIT YINCHERHES I TN ITAS WN
MTHWIIN AEND IE HAV TO JTUS
ELKELI RONSEEA CNDOLTR A SEE
APATWH HNSPE ANDST TRU MY BYOD
AND T ANDHESSRO PCE
.OH
Y.SO, RR
WE WR'E'ON GNAPENORP U F
ONESQUTIYOEVS ER INENT  JUS
W
TEMINU
ONI D''NO KWOW HO TSK AS THI
QU
ONTI.
I W I WSAS A IOOT G THE TND E
TOFHE
OO BK.
ASI WINHI TNK YGOUAL TK A LOT
TABOUNGLA PYI THE GEAMIK L
E
ABAPTOU CMALITISNGLA PYIHE T
WMEGAHITOU YR BYODR O
OR
NGLOSI
U YOIKELFE L
YOE U.
WOR ONIINNGNGLOR SIRE G.AT
'ON D'
TW. KNO
I DON''NO KWBO AUT THE
AM .
ELI FEIK LE WTHA IO D
AV HE
ITCLARSONY  I WNHEIN WNGNIIT WH
IDOUTS T OEFE  GHEAME LBYIK
INDOG SNGETOMHILFS  AFULIILNGS A
WRBOG INA .OK
.-HMMMM
'ON D'OWT KNF I TTHA SORF O
DESI.
'THAT 'SELINEFIT AYTOM MEN WREHE
ETHCTUALRI WNGTIT.F O I
YEAHLLUL FFIGINT IWE IS DIR
BE MEUSTOSF THIM TE Y'O'RE
OEDUS T JIKTUS LNG BEEIOO LK
IT
''IKE SURHICEFA T.NG
SO IT ME TUS B LCHSU AE IKA80 1
E
EEGRN TUR TOE LEIK' I 'MY
.SEMYLF
NO'D'KI LSOO M ANGT
ISTHIKS I LYE M IL.ERNTNA
IEA M INOV LEDT. I
I WOV LETIRING AND TTHAOR FT THA
PA THAEA RNSO BUTOB N
YOD
LYREALOV LESNGRI WTI
.YO
UT JUSOV LE TT.HA
TLOVEHEH OO TE B.LE CAR B IUT
YEER MAHIS
LEAB.
,YEAH BUT I TNKHIT THAT THAIK L
E
FOSCU T ANDE LHEIKISXE ERCFE O
ORHE T ENCERXPIEE T JT HAISTUS
LI' D ION 'TLEEHISBOAY W A
H
EICYSALE,RCXEISUT BW K INO
ENWH PPLEOE TBOKAL ANI RUTUN
NO
TIME AN'HE TY'IKRE LE, I
HATE IT,UT BT I FLSEEE LIKT' 'S
O
FYAT SISG.IN
'I'TEDD AIC
'MIK LE, OH ISTND UERDANT THA
AT RINELPNSIOHIO T MYXPER
E
WITHNGRI WTI
.MH
M.YE
.AH
AHYE.
N'I DO 'TTNKHI I BOU WLD FAI
YIFOUE WERIK LE' I' BMULUTEAIF
ANTI W IRI INGSO S E FYASORE M
ANT' 'LLTOS TAAT GYRE IND A'T'
I
D YKEOU'O' D YTOU'O'T WTANO T
BETHANGRI WTIS I SO HDAR
LYREALO SAR HDEL WL,T' 'LYRES AL
BEY FUTILLN.ITWRTE
HOIT SDULEA RDT I IT ISLL A
I
MEAN MO SYANEF  OTH EAYSSSRE A
KE S MOVGINND ANE OPEOD S
MAWSIN WDONT IOO SY MANLD WOR
S
ATTHRE AOT BHETOM CPLYELXOTI
TAD ANTOAMYLL F AIAILRTAMHE T S
I
M SMEOH.UC
ANK YOU FORNG DOIHI TSAL TOT
O
E WRE ANA GONPE ON UPOR F
TIQUESS.ON
A ISOFBONYDYTS WAN TO ASK
QU
S,TIESON PASEE COMO THE T
HOCRMIOP ANESEOPL AREIN LING
UP I AMNG GOI TO ASKST QUENSIO
UROMFR OALIR VTUNCUD AIE
'ON D'NOT KRE WWHEHE TAM CAER
IS, BUTEL HLOALIR VTUNCUD AIE
EY
M'O'SN I THEIR VALTUIR VALTU
CEDIAUENY ND A M.ECNIES
SOROMAT KIEN I C,CAHIGOAV H
EO
RD HUEAF OR OAL TKO TTH OER
LSDEIN BUY BGKACIR THEHO PS?TOO
DANHA WTRE AHE TIV MIROT
IS
OIIN D?
SO
SO TSHI L IS IEIK'' I AER VY
PA
ARICRTULIOOS PIT
MOSTNGOR WKIEL MOD' DSON 'TEAV
THE ABITYO T DOT THA ORAV H
E
SSACCE TO
IT.
IOHI TNK TTHA'HE TREM'S
RECO
TIERNVSAOUS ONAR COPIGHT
SOD ANAL, YW KOUNON I THE A
F
ETHNENT IER G ITNERENALIK LE I
WOAYD ST THAIT WHEV RGEEN --
WANDERH ITEVSSNEYO ELYTIENAL I
I
NDF OE LIKUT PNGTIHE TIR
IM
ESAG T OUT
REHE.
THI HAKIN TT 'REHE'S A LOT OF
SANVCOER AONTIS OUNRODIPERWNSH
IFSPECALICLY INHE TINOD MEL
GIN
.STDURY
NO' D IO'T THI TNK'HE TY'RE
HERTHEN BASEE A LOT OFT THA
TH''
RU TE.
LIKEHE TY CA'T A IORFFD
T.YE
.AH
T WIAN BHA TTIOREFE  TET GO YOU
YSGU.
OTHISST QNEUENS IEA RYLL
GALRELY
ATRE.
ANI WO DTE TKASBO AUTAC R IE
N
BLICPTER PCEN.IO
WHO Y DOOUHI TPL PNKEOCT REEAED
TOOU YURO  TBLDINES AS
DPOOPSEEGO T MAN C ANDDIAR BND A
--OW H TOLIEX SUATYNT IACERT
TE WTHHITHSSNE E ACNITYIGMBUII
,
T ITS INT INGESERTIO THI TNK
OFE LIK FMRO BRREDES LIN TO- -
LIT THAID VS.EO
SIRTTAHE T BKOOITFF O WH --
BETEUS ITAS W I HADOM CE OUT
DAN I WASE LIKAI WTHI TS
TIERNVSAONUN ARODEXUATYLIO
IKDAN LOW EEMP RMEERNTLLEAYN I
A
CMUSIEO VIDYEA RLLDSEM RINE OF
ISTH, B IUTIL WAYL S I MN,EA I
TH
ATK INTH WHO TSEEN ABLACK
E
HHAN VEADT' 'SUCO S MH.OR WSE
IEA M LNEIKIK LEHO WITUT AOUBT
IA REACRE SLTEYPOTEST THA
E
TOINY. PLA
'I' IS AANNSEND TVE ENUGHOH YOU
,KNOWT IAS MHE TIRICUSID VEO
ANY THEER W IEN CTRONOL
HEY
THAVETL BOATOLA E WHR.OTE HE
T SEOFS SS IUEOUATTH YNOW.
ARE CRA, BUTT I IS A S
IR
GTHIN OOI GNGNN IHA TT VEO
GTHATSOE ONHIN I TSOO BKCH WHI
S
IK LE AM INTR CON?OL
'KELI I 'MNGOIHI TSNG THI
'THAT 'SM FORPOF  OEMT.RMWEEN
BUEL WL, I SHI TNK DHESOE
W
ICARDUT, B B NEL WLO,UT BT I
S
NTSO INGESERTISEEC BAUT IAS W
LI YOUAD H YOUNO KW, RLLEAY
TFTLEISIN FEMTIS ANDIG RG-WHTIN
E
LEOPOT BHGAY SINIK LEHI TS
VI
ODE IS ARA TSHIKND LEHE WN
HAESDO TTAP HNPETH IN
ISCO
TRUNY?
SO INO KWHE TYOM CEHEOG TET
R.E
OM,AH SHINGS TT HAIAT HE
CABASIY.LLAR WMI
AHYE.
YES.
HEGO ACE SADININOU Y L
UEDP
T.FIRS
RRSO
ALRELYOO C AS ANG YOU WANOM
HO W
WASAV NGATIGINER HAR CROU YR
NDDEINPENDCEEN A
OU YR
NIFEMI
TYNI.
DANOT NO TEN MATONTI DYGIN M
TWITHRT HHEEAHEACND AIN KDF O
THREAI FLUNDS AEC REJON
ALPEESCILYRO FMN AND I
TRU.
THAT ISO SAS E ANDND AUI QCKO T
WJERECTENOM K AD INOF.THNOER
AHYE.
I MN,EA INK THIHA TTHI TS IS
SO IINTHGV'' HIG MHTEREA MAY S
THISGA AAU BINECEA ISE RTYLL I
OWAS T ONEFHEWAAK TEA TYST HAI
HATHWI AK. BOO
IN, MEA IRO W ITETO T
INATSTVEIGER EEXP TNCIEESTHA I
HA AOT LF O SMEHAUN ARONDD A I
GHT AT IAS WOI GONG T
K
CKBA T ATHEOO BK B ANDEE, LIK
'ATTH'HES TTOM ME'HA TT'HES W IE
OUSHLDAV HE DOMEON S
HIETNG
ERDIFFRTEN O TTO AS W SUPSTID
WORHYOUID D YOMOM CPR
EIS
SEYOUR T ILFNAYSHI W
DIDOUGR AEE TOO DS THIH
BL
HA,AH WVER WND ATHA IV''
RESEDIZ I TTHAOM WEN TT'S
ALACTU ALYLL REAYOT N AEA HHYLT
SEEREXCIND A IHI THANK TNG YTOU
O
EENME NDO TRN LEAO GI
LVEMTHSERE AES B.AK
ANDNDER TANSTDHEAR L TRGE
S
THEISO PRERLNAIC CHOESHA TTEA L
H
TEMO TSEHOACEA HRTSHE A TNDO
OSTHE BTARUL KD OITREF ALSIE
WH
IHIC K YS,OUW,NOYAR PTLHY W
R
EE OTTHOO BK IS, YOUW, KNO I
N'D'T JTUSHI TT TNKHA MYIF L
HASEE BN A P ODUROCTFY M
CECHOI
'LSS A C TOHE ATUULRENDHE T
DWORL WHA TTLIE VE INND A I
KTHINT' 'SYEA RLLMP ITANTOR F
UNYOGOM WENO TN ITI PAR TLACURO
ARNO NOTE BRDO  SHAN O
LVEMTHSE.ES
OHCOIC NE .OL
GOAD AHE
I W WASNGDEONRIF IPL PEONE I
GEEL RAARR YOUOLLORS KDIN
OF IFIR THEONPI ONI OSNOU YF I
TH
EY SRTTAEDGAK TINE MOR
OUSERIHAYSL CFTEDNG AER YOU
OUEDEN YIN BRUS OSESTESTR ARP
O
BUSESS.
.NO
MORE IY THE SRTTAED T YINAKG
U
SMORELYIOERUSE LIKIT WLLH A
STESTHE ZAMAIGTIANONTIS FSTD UF
T'OU Y'ALRE TBONGKI A.UT
,YEAH I MN,EA IEFINELYHI T
H
YATOUNO KW IN THELD WORF O
AIMSKSND YOU KNO KW,IEYL LIP
QU'HE TRE 'SEIK INK THIT THA
WHENEO PEPL SEE WENOMIN TAKG
LNTCORO OFHE TIRGE IMA L AND
K
USIN WHA HTASN BEESE UD BY
ROTHEE EO PPLTO TAV HEHE TIR
HOWN PTLUSEPLEOEIN DEF AELITY
E
KELI,H O W,OWAY MBEHE S''
SSSIBUNE WAV SVYRTEHAVE SO, YES
INKHIN IN SEOMAY WS,OU Y
KN
T TOWHAEEAS H B A PT OFT, I
DTBU IO, YOUW, KNOHE TK BOO
AMLYON C A OEUTEE WK, AGOUT B
I'MOP HGINT THA THEISOO BK
MA IMOE REULACMPTFATN  ITH
Y.WA
TBULS AO IDNHO SUL'' AOR WRYUTBO
IT SOUC MHIG RHTIK LET. THA
TH''HAHE T COUENC YO DAV HE
THE TERU FER HO
ENRID.
VEWHOER YROUDRI FEN WS IHOIK LE
SLPOU Y BLD YRUS B
ESS
LIKER  YOUTUACALE TRUDRI FENN I
FELI.
DYEAHHOSOE S UW'HA TT'IKS LE A
GOEROU CNTELABANCO T AS TLLHI
OTLIR KEL GIRN O WIR GL
R.
S.YE
,NO IHI TNKEEM FALRI FPSDSENHI
GEE ARHUOR ILYMP
NTTA.
S.YE
HI E
LYMI.
KTHAN YOU SO FUC MHOM CG.IN
E NMYAMMAS I I AN,N' I'M A
CO
EGLLETU S
NTDE.
YOU ORAPETEWE BET SENO MYAN
STINDUESRI MRO FMGELODIN TO
EPENTRSHNEREUR N AIPND
LITURARE AND I W WASNGDEONRI
WHEDV AICOU Y WLDE GIVO T
UNYOGOM WAN AND TIRHE 20SN O
OWNG TIRHEUA SEXTYLIND A
TRITENGSEHESSRO PFE
NAIOL
SFEARVEND A ERL ONVEPIAPNG
BE
THEETWN YO AEMS .HAU VE
ANTHKOUOR FIN COM
I, I MN, I THI TNKTHANE O
TH
GIN' 'VEEARN AEDNDHI TS
IUNSODS'T' TIK LEHED KINF O
TH
G.IN
IOTDV AEICRO AREDUN P
ANY
MANDOOHEOTRH I ADND''IKE B L
E'
'VEHARDEA T M ATLIILONIMES
'I'S NOTPF HELUT,UL BHE TN Y
OU
BCOME TKAC
IOT.
U'Y'REE, LIKLL AIGHT
'A'T WSHAHE TY IHA TT WASH
D
CEADVI
UM,TH DO ATK INTHINRU TSTOUG YR
GUTND AOL F YWILONGSTR OUIN
.
THE'KNYOS U .OW
IHI TNKHA TTRE THE''TU C AULRE
OROF SIKOFT  LIN FAD REN MTO
LI,NOOU Y KPL PW,EOARE E
G
TOUI GDEOU YHAND A T'T'RU T
E,U
T IHI TNKN ITI PARLACURIT W
ORMENTL  WSILCK QBEUIO TOR ST OO
U
SSTAY YIK LEUL SOUHODIT DO
THAY WNDIK LEON D'' LTEISN
TOFRSOUELND A WHAVER DANAN C
BET SOR OFIS DE.SSMIIV
E HAVOU FNDT THAAK TGINHA TT
ROCEVI FPL PMEOEOTAS H NEE BNAD
E
FULPLEOR F MHA TTADNS ITED KIN
OFHANGOI WT IT WAN TOO. D
IN MEAOB NYOD I TNKHIOU WLDAV H
A
E LIDIKRITE AOO B OKFSSS EAY
TABOU SEXLITY
KET' THA 'SHATHA T'T' THE
,CKTIETNOOU Y KUTW, BT' '
THSOMEHAGIN T ITEL FIOPAT SSTENA
OUABTOUND A YNOW, WTHHEERR O
T'TNO 'SSSUC SCELFU IT AST LEA
ONCA GEDO T BT A NHTNGNO KWI
TH
ATID I DT WHA IAR CEDBO A.UT
ST TSORUURG INYO
UT G.
ANTHKOUCHO  SMU
.TH
U.K ANYO
YE
LY EHIMI
KTHANOU Y S MUC FORHA S INGRI
N
ETH. CUT
LASTMBEP STE O IERS ONEF THE
TEGREANG TSTHILRS ADYEA020.
, I GSSUE MST QYUENIO IS YOU
ME
DIONTNEBOUT IIK LE GSSUE
BE
GIN CRESIONDELID KEUBLI
TYOPPRER B,UTEI BNGON COLTRND A
NGRACUTI IOU YRAMTANSGR AND
AB
IKTOU L THECCESTYBISILI
THEEOU Y FIKL L YEE HOUAVO T
HAEOO T PEPLOW HO DOU Y
NAHATEGA TT? NOW
IN, MEAIASP EEC KYLL IHIWNO TS
YTHAT' DOUON 'TE SRE IT
SYOURT TONHAUC MHN I YROU
IN LRAAGME I TUE GSSOUHRGH
GOOU TGHRS TGHHI PCEROSSF O
ETKELI GAMNGTI FNIOVE ERT.GH
OWKELI HOOU YTR CONOLT? THA
LIUCOW H M H YHOU TINAVG
OSH
EARND A H MOWHUC PEOEHI T
K
TTHATYHE YNO KWOU B TAUECSEYHE
U E SEYOHEEREVYW.RE
ATTH'' AEA RYLLD GOOST QUEN.IO
I'UR FMIGGIN O ITUT ERYVEAY D
FOLEXA EMP WH ITMY S ATOU Y
OWKN, ONE PNTOI I WN'A'RI STHA
HIS FEACND AN THEE HAS WNGET GTI
IRAPAZZ ANDHA TT WAS ATHNOER
EAMEXPLF O MED KINF ONGAN WTI
L NTCOROEEDAN FIKNGLI L
YU
,KNOWF I'HE TRE 'SNAON BEMA ISGE
YOF MON S
IAN WT TOE HO COSICHNESRE A
GOBE TGO HE T OUTN IHE T
WORL
'I' NSOTHE TDE I BALUTT' '
U
, KNOW'I'AYMYS  WF OTR CON
D
ALSOE LIKOU YNO KW, ITRT STAED
L FTOEE LEIKOR MOFE  A HEDAEACH
TO T TRYOTE PROCTMAIS H IGEM FRO
BE T OGUTREHEHA TN T JOTUS
ELKELI R AAXND BE KE, 'I'
SOK
.AY
'H'SCA HE  BNE OUTN I T WLDOR
N
THD AT FETLSEE B MR TETO
I TNKHI IS'T'STJU AO-AY D-TY,DA
YOEEOWKN FUTNGLI GCK CHE ASND
SO OFGAY SIN LEIK WTHAHA W
OMSEL CLERTFOABND AVE E WNNHETFE
I WASTI WRIHING T BSKOOID DECGIN
ATWH I WAND TESHO AR AND WHY
U KN,HA TTAS W KDINF OUS J
T
AS W MY ITAS W WLTT HAFEHT RIG
AND,OU Y BNO KWNGEI REAY
KICHEC W INGNYSHIT MNFEL IHE T
HAYWA TT IEF DYITINEL TSE UDO
TNO I UD SETOEE FL LOUE,IK Y
OWKN, IOU WLDEV N EERNVE IF
SO
TBOMEDY MCHOUEDEHATER I
EVDUL NAVER HE TUGHOHTSEEC BAUWO
IWNE YOUNO KW TT TYHELD WOU
H
HEKIN SS''OWDERU N
'MIT LETL BITOR MER IENT
D
INAK TARGIN CEF  OSEMYLFHE RATR
THINOR WRYGUT ABOAYHE T W' '
E
D.EIRCVE
INOM SEAY WSOU YR''UCKY AS A
ERWRIT B TAUECSET'H' ALIS KE
REOSEON TOC SLIA
RE
SHTILAONS.IP
'I'E LSIK HER HETEAV IE LIK
ARESTHE  T MEYS.UGHOHT
THS IHA WT IHI TNKBO A TUTSEHE
IOTUSIAT.NS
ISTHS ILL AY M CATPLOMICED
GSELFEIN
''IK LE WRE GATAY OF
ESADDR YNGSI,W, KOUNOLL AHE T
TINTHGS PTHAPLEOERE
PR OTIECNG. YNOU
ITL'S  YKEOU D'O'E HTAVO T
TOJPREC
OU Y.
IHERE
ITS.
CAYOU ND REAT, IOU YNO KW
TOS.Y LLYE
ANTHKOU YOMOR F CG.IN
'I'URM COWUSIO NHA 'YOT U'RE A
MOM AT AESUS BINER OSWN
AT Y AREHOROU TONHTUGS E' 'VE
SEPL C AOUELERT AIC ISNEW N
AZ MRKAGREIN OHE TEW NOR YRKEYO
LIOUABT KEHE TALL OF THEL GIR
ROSSBO T ANDOWT THAOR STF O
I
KEAM CE OUTF OE LIK GNDRI
ELTCUURIKND A LEN WEOMAV HE TO
ALSO Y,OUNO KWAR C TEOTNHE
HE R
RNMATETI IALNSTSNC ANDHE TY
E
CH NDRILENT TOWH'OU Y' MRE A
OM
WHOLNO PEHE DOU YNOMEN? TF OTHA
EWHEROUO D Y SEERS YOUFEL
AD
TALLT?HA
TAHYE AOINE O P.NT
WIAS IIK LE,EE NDO TRI WTE
A
GIRLOSS,SS EAYND A TNHE IOR S
F
YESSAHEAS W TSS EAY TTHA YOU
ALKTAEDUTBO THEVEAL MDING GSOI
HITO TAT VSACD N IOANFRTSO O
GBEIN OIK LEY.KA
MLLWE IHTIG AS WLELE B THE ONE
O
ELL THEHI BAT SNGTSUI RHER
HIAN TUYS G
IN, MEA I TNKHI TTHAIT CAPISALM
ISEA RYLL OOU RGHNONVE ERYE
D
IHI TNK TT,HAOU YNO KW WENOM
THIS FLIEENGATF  OTH''OT NT' 'S
REODTE THERSON CVE
IOA.
I'MER INTINTEESD IN HAV Y OGFOU
N
, I HEAVO T B TOMECEHEAN M
I
E HAVO TOM BEC TEHES BOSN I
DEORR TO BEIE VDWES A
SUULESCCSF
VE EN IFHA TTEA MNSEI B ANGN
--HO W LIKOE D'S'TAY PR FAI
TGEWA,T'H'T' TSHAT'S E GEAM I
HAVEOY PLANDOR F AIASP EECYLL
HARDN IRD OERO T BEAK TENDOOU
YOURISLND IHI TNKHA T WTASE
UNFOUNRTECEAT BTSEAU I DN'I'
,MEANOU Y RNO KW, CLEANGHAE AT
TH
E SEAM TIM
ASSOAL WE NIC TOEE SOM SEOM WEN
ANESUS BINNDSSE A ACE PNDLA
F
RPOWEHA TTE W' DO'TMA NOREEYLL S
LABACKSHO THE TL  GIRSSBOE T
OMPHENONENHEND A T WAYT THAO S
OMNYMA WE  WENERCCLDHE ALENTOUAB
INAY WHA TN'I T DOT'T ATK INTH
THWEE REN AME BNGEIEL HD
AC
UNTAEAS W AOLS R TATELED
E
SMXI.
SOE' 'REUS JTON GNAE TAKEEHR
MOUE QIOSTNSHR T,EE S YOUE.UR
AYOK.
GOKAYD.OO
L AL
GHRIT.
,HI MYE NAM RS IEO AND TNKHA
YO FORNG BEI HE.ER
MY QNSTUEIOS IT WHA WLDOU
MN
NLEARRERO FM THINADG K? BISOO
YHEOM RAN, EOTH FOROMIN
G.
UMKNYO, U OW TNKHIT THA I
WREBOHI TS OKH WIT M IENN MDIN
INWAOM SE AU BYSECSEHE TREER W
E
THREEER AEN M TTH' I'M TLO CSEO
WHO IELTIK LELL REA'DIY DN
'T
RSUNDEHYNDTA W' 'D GET S
IOEMOT UL NAORBOETPS AUTNY A
OMBNUERUA SFIT AONTISY' TNDHE'D
OKIND BEIKE,N M IEA I GET I
T
LIT' 'SD HARHT RIGND A I
I
FEIK LE SOST FRUTERADHA TIT
WA
'S'NG DTOI AOO GDOB JF O
NIPLEXAIT WNGHAT' 'SIK LE TO BE
AIRNGOU G OLA BRE AN WOM I
NTH
ISORLDND A WNHE IRO WTEHE T
OKBO IT KEP I DI'WAT NTO T
OSTJU T I BEN IIO OBVLYUS W
ASH
KIINNGUT ABOOM WEN A BOT L,
I
ANTE ITEO T BCC AESIESBLO T
NMEO SHA TTHE T COU
IATEPONTELY LLFESSOM CPA.NAIOTE
DAN EMPHETIH  WCITT'ATWH I
'S
TLIKE WBEO  A
ANOM.
ANTH
YOK U.
KSTHAN
.YE
.AH
EMI.
HI.
,HINA MY  IMESH, OY MAM NES I
DR
.EW
OF P IPLEOE'T'AR HDO TWIEL TL  L
A
S.SK
A SIEEOT LF ONG YOU PEOE IN
NDREHE A' ' A 2M3NDLL A MY
FRRESND A3. 2
IAS WUS JTDE WONIKNGRI L YEOU
TALK A LUT AOTBOTR CON AOLND
LI AEI BNGEBLO TLI OR KE
FE OGINUT OFTR CON AOLND
STIMEME HIK LEOWAR HD ITS IO
O
GANAVI THA
I WAS JTUSDE WON FNGRIOREO SOM
GEUR O ANDIK LTISTE AR
T
USBECAE A LOTF OXPHE T EESIEERNC
THATOU YAL TKBO AUTE WERN I
R
YEARL
0S 2.
IWHAT TSHET BES AICDVET THA
U
VEHA FORE LIK NINIGAVATGT THA
ANDEA RARYLL HSSIN TTHA
L NTCOROFE DINIFPANTRE SS?CE
IEA MT'N, 'SO S HARN WH'OU Y'RE
EC,23 BSEAU' YOU 'RE3ND AEO PEPL
LEAR OE,IKH, YO' 2RE3OLEA YR
O
N.MA
ATWHO D YOU KNDWNO AHY W WLDOU
NOUYO KW,VE ENF IOU Y ARE
RTINSEGINOU YROU Y ARNCGEY LE
'ERTHE'S ATA CERINUN AMOOFT
SASMDIISDIANL D RUSTST IN MEA I
K THINAWINBEG .E AROF
ION'TAN WT TOAY SHE T SEAM
GTHINUT BF OTE PRO YINCTGFRSOUEL
ANIN HAVG AME FRAF OENEF RER.CE
'ATTH'SOT N NOTNGET LTIHI TSNG
NDLANAER PSOYLLT THA CAN BE
AFULPLND A YSOUIN KD OFRI TE
O
IN FROCOD NTAU BLECS'OU Y'RE
INGOGO TET GCHO  SMUACUS PHB
K.
TBU I'T' IT' RSLLEAYOU T.GH
' DIO'TE HAVOU YNOW, IH WIS
TTHATREHE WASOM SEIN K OD
FGU
KEBIDOOO T TS.HI
INK THIUS JTWI KNO YNGFRSOUEL
ANLL RDEAY TGSTRUINOU YR
THATEAHE T RIOCTNST THAOU YRE A
INGETTN' AGRE 'T OAUECSE WFHO
UYO. ARE
I'AU BSECTH OSEF D WOE RLDAN
ETHTU CULREWEHA TT  IXI ESTN Y
U
QLASTNSTUEIO H' '. LMEE
TH YKOU SH MOUCOR FOM CG.IN
MYAM NE ISYD L.IA
,UM F IDISINHE THEOO BK AOU CEPL
YSDA
GO A.
IOV LEDT. I
,OHEA YH, END A ILLECSPIAED LYOV
E CPTHAERDAL CLE W THEZIOOES
FID ANDETENILYE MADE M AEIT LTL
NAOTEMIO
I A,NDOV LEHA TTOU YALK
AB TTHEIOEL RAT WHINSP YHITROU
CAM MOBE IEUSHI TNK YOUNOWHE T
ONLARETIHAIPSH T ATOM WAN HAS
WI
ER H.
MOM ISUC SH ANTAMP IOREC ANTSP
F
IF LE.
SOAND Y MUE Q WIOSTNAS B
ORE
INWRIT B TGHEKOO OR BORET I
UBSWA P.SHLIED
DIVEOU Y E SRITOW DN WURH ITYO
ANMOM D YNO KE HWAVSE THE
CO
TIERNVSAHASON T T YTOUKAL
ABTN IHE TOO BK ANDF IO, S
HKELI, T DOWID?T HAGO
OHHA TNK. YOU
INT MEASKO T AHA TST QTUEN.IO
'I' WIK LELEL WOUTHA Y DRAD
GHTHOUT OTHEK? BOO
UM, YOUW, KNO I IRE SHAD
EVNGYTERHI W MH ITMY AOMN' IT'S
ANNGNG OOION CIORSVEATNE LIK
L
MAINTISE CTELOIOEL RAT.HINSPS
IN, MEA IHI THANK TT K YOU
WO
WHAT I TEDRI D TOO WLL RASEAY
ERVEGI HKNYO, U .OW
TOO T BE ASAT EMPTIHEC LE I
KNHA TTTHVE ERYNGIN I TK BHEOO
ID D OUT OE LFOVND AUT OF O
REDESIO TTE PRO MCTEND AS A A
PAEL MNTYSF, IE LIKAV HEO T
ACPTT THA I'' GENAON B
IMECRFTS A AEN PAR ATND
'EYTH'VERE EN TT MHEOS
NTLLWE-IEDTIENONN,ER PSOOU Y
SOWKN IOI GNGHE T'R'NG GSOIO T
BENGHIST THARE A MSSAESGE
T
UYONO KT JW,U'ON D'ANT LD THE
HAYWA TTOU YEN INTHEMO TUT B
IAHYE,'T' ANDT' 'S O AN
OG
ERCONV.TISAON
THLOS  IA IKOFT  LEND A W
M
ARNDOU AHE MOTR RNSATELIO
P.
,WELL YHA TNKOUMI ELYO SUC MH
FO
NGCOR MI DO T
ANK YOU FLL AORIN COM
G.TH
U K ANYOH. MSOUC
DSEKWEENN ON-S CPA